[Music]
it is time for this week's pet project
amy lee joins us from nspca
and you have someone who needs a safe
and good home really cute dog
named miss betty isn't she beautiful
so miss cindy is just a beautiful sweet
one-year-old girl she's a healer mix and
betty's actually quite special um
so betty actually came to us as a puppy
and she had
a triple infection in her lungs so she
actually
if she gets overly excited you'll hear
the sort of snorting sound so
we really do need to find her a really
special home that's that's mellow
because we have to kind of control
her activity level but that doesn't mean
that excludes her from anything else
because she's a really wonderful
wonderful companion
um we just need to find that right home
for her right so grand central station a
house where kids are coming going maybe
other animals are running all over the
place
not necessarily the best spot for miss
betty that's not the home from his betty
so miss betty
although she wants to play we kind of
need to control it a little bit so we
can go on
easy walks with her we you know yard
with a little bit of
fetch is fine you know this is not the
dog that you want to take on like these
giant marathon runs this is just a dog
that you want to take easy controlled
walks with and kind of control her
her activity and her energy level here
at the shelter she gets really over
stimulated there's a lot of smells and a
lot of people coming around
so she's overly you know excited and you
can hear her snorting but
she actually has lived in a foster home
while she was recovering
and she did wonderful she loves the home
environment so if we can find her a nice
mellow home environment that she is a
people person she loves people
um so especially you know this is a
lover and a dog that keeps
her on the couch with um and she's so
she's sweet she's just special
yeah she looks really sweet so is she on
a special diet or does she take meds
she actually just takes apaquo which
kind of helps control some of the
inflammation that
that she's experiencing so this is kind
of a lifelong thing that the damage um
is permanent unfortunately but it he
acts and lives a normal life other than
just
not being able to go full blown you know
running you know she just
just easy going you just gotta go easy
with her she looks like an absolute love
all right
thank you very much amy if you are
interested in adopting a pet including
miss betty go to nevadaspca.org or call
them at that phone number